[Music]
so welcome my name is Bill Isaacs and
I'm part of the Center for
organizational learning at MIT for those
of you who I don't know which is some
I'm happy to have the privilege of
introducing our two speakers this
morning and the way we'll do it is to
have one speak first and then have an
introduction for him and then the second
and the first speaker will be a man
named Karl Henrik robear who is from
Sweden and is an associate professor in
medicine in Sweden and a cancer
specialist who some years ago started an
environmental organization for
sustainable development in Sweden and
this organization is called the natural
step and it's had quite an impact in
that country and his aim essentially was
to educate the nation about
environmental concerns and he's had some
success in that I would say essentially
he what he's here to do is to talk about
his experience and we'll hear from him
in a moment we also have with us Paul
Hawken who's a writer and entrepreneur
and I'll introduce him more formally in
a little while after Carl is finished so
it is a great pleasure to have these two
here with us it's significant in my mind
because we are interested in discovering
ways that business and the environment
could actually talk to one another to
have a conversation even and
I see that what we're doing here as the
beginning of that conversation as far as
the efforts of the learning center at
MIT go and we'll see where we go from
here but I feel like
it's a certain seed ready to be planted
today so without further ado does it
work up there now okay you hear my voice
clearly I'm a cancer scientist and the
cancer doctor as you just heard and my
scientific work has been entirely
concerned with cancer cells from
patients who have attended the clinic
which I've been heading so I've done
both things treating cancer disease
patients and doing scientific work on
their cancer cells and it has been a
systems approach trying to understand
what goes wrong in this little micro
cosmos which is a cell and it will it
was this was the starting point for this
environmental organization because on
that level economy it doesn't mean
anything
you can't argue with cells you can't
urge them to succeed in processing
mercury or breakdown freons or survive
without force fault
still it turns out that also economists
and politicians are constituted by cells
so it should serve as a rather neutral
non aggressive starting point for
consensus and the idea was to come
beyond our tendency to fight when it is
about environmental issues and economy
to reach beyond that point and try to
build up a very solid intellectual
knowledge the idea was that one part of
the fight in Sweden is that people pay
Greenpeace and other organizations to do
something and then they go on living
like if nothing has happened so there
you leave it to pros to do something but
this the idea here was to build up
professional groups and the first group
of scientists for the environment to
provide their professional skills for
the environment and after that we have
commenced and started and initiated and
supported doctors for their might meant
nurses for the environment economists
for the environment industry leaders for
the environment and so forth 17 such
professional groups and what they do is
that by idealistic reasons they try to
find out in what way can our
professional skills support the
environment so instead of paying someone
else to do something they enter the
environmental movement with their
professional skills this was the idea we
now have 7,000 such people involved in
those 17 professional groups and the
natural step is a sort of Federation to
link them together support them and help
them and educate them and what we do is
that we share the same system over you
which is elaborated by scientists for
environment this was the first task to
see what we agree upon because it seems
that everyone else is dealing about what
we don't agree upon and the news may
papers and media are stuffed with what
we do not agree upon but we turn that
upside down what do we agree upon so I
invited scientists all over Sweden to
see what we could agree upon as to
intellectual stuff which could be useful
to business leader and politicians this
wasn't the task and I explained to them
that if we cannot agree upon anything it
must be published because we have been
studying those issues in thousands of
years and if we haven't still reached
any knowledge which is relevant and that
we can reach a decision and consensus
about it should be published it's
astonishing and they realize that this
is an intellectual challenge so they I
succeeded to make them interested in
this and my point my ticket entering
ticket was the same since I can Society
so I invited physicists and whatsoever
and together we explained the system
ecology and superimposed on that economy
which belongs to the same system what
can we agree upon and I realized from an
intuitive level that the only thing we
can reach a consensus on is the core
knowledge the trunk and the branches the
general principles of the system the
time dynamics in it and so forth but the
details all the leaves we will leave to
the specialists amongst those leaves to
and I had a feeling of that as long as
we can see the trunk and the branches
all the specialists about the leaves can
put them on themselves opening up for
creativity now all systems are
constituted like that there is a solid
structure the trunk and the branches and
are all the details the leaves for
instance your brains human brain is
exactly organized and it even looks like
that and it functions in a way that it
thank you
it uses division of labor so that part
of the blade takes care of that that
part takes care of that that part takes
care of that and then this computer has
an extraordinary capacity to communicate
between those parts particularly in
females unfortunately for me they have
it easier to comprehend the whole system
in the same time therefore they are also
more worried about the environment that
males are all over the world because
they can take in more knowledge in the
same term without losing track of the
whole and we know why from a
neurological reason - now the point is
that in spite of that we are geniuses
when it is about to handle complex
systems as individuals even the male's
are geniuses in comparison with the most
complex computer we have it is the silly
toy in comparison with this computer
when it is about handling complexity in
spite of that we behaved like idiots
together which is very sad and the
reason is that we do the same as the
brain we implement division of labor but
we find it much more difficult to
communicate between one another than it
is within one genius parts of the brain
to communicate to one another and the
other part which i think is much more
important is that we very often get very
sloppy about the trunk and the branches
so an organization generally don't train
about what is the sole instruction of
our purpose why do we exist what is if
we want to do what are the
non-negotiable parts of the structure
this company or this local authority is
supposed to handle
on the other hand here we find the
challenge because if a company or an
organization or a team starts really
hard to train about the solid structures
and then they do division of labour an
organ an organization can become more
intelligent than the individual players
because a lot of people together master
more skills and competence than any
individual one example of that is that
when the Americans wanted to go to the
moon they collected metallurgy
specialists fuel specialists computer
specialists astronomist whatever and
they trained over the same
non-negotiable structure of the system
and they had exactly the same you want
it that the moon resisted the people who
thought that it was some kind of
psychological projection were not
invited into that and they had exactly
the same idea of all that and they
trained over the same solid structure
and after while this team could go
around an electric car on the moon which
is a project so complex that no single
human brain can comprehend or achieve
that result our problem is that we can't
run electric cars here where we live and
where the socio-economic benefit would
be so much greater than to have it on
the moon and the reason is that we
haven't done this we haven't tried to
study what is non-negotiable in the
system that we are in charge of so to
speak so we have to move into a new
house
ecology means the knowledge about the
house and since your genius is as
individuals but have a tendency to
become dumb together like all humans if
particularly if the group is too large
we have to ask you as individuals how do
you run a project like that moving into
a new house a sustainable one this time
and you will do the same you know that
there were a lot of measures thousands
of small details that must be done to
fulfill this but you start to organize
it immediately and you have in your head
you have the time axis for the project
and let's say that you and your husband
or you and your wife has got a new job
and it will be in Washington
and you are going to start your new job
in three years from now you know that
there is a history having given you a
certain economy and a few other things
furniture whatever which will be
implemented into the new house living
you have a present year where the
telephone calls to banks people selling
houses whatever and then when the
project is completed your brains
immediately without any plan identify
four new non-negotiable branches the
trunk is the project of moving to the
new house and the four branches are as
non-negotiable solid the first is that
the house must be in the neighborhood of
Washington close enough for both to
travel to their jobs this is the
geographical one the second one is that
you must be able to afford the new house
living non-negotiable the third is that
it must fulfill the functions of your
family if you are alone or five kids and
whatever and there are more such things
and the fourth is that it must fulfill
certain minimal criteria of how standard
now you arrange thousands of things to
converge into the fulfillment of all
four branches so you put on the leaves
without violating any of the major rules
and you do that automatically if you
compute this function just like that you
even find it easy particularly females
to move to a new house now your do this
so skillfully that it never happens that
your only fool field three of those
because since non-negotiable system
conditions must be fulfilled all of them
it doesn't happen that someone ends up
in Florida are trying to figure out how
things could go so wrong or move into a
house without a roof and so forth so you
arrange the projects that it converging
to that and now the task is for the
scientists for the environment to see if
this project can be defined in the same
way is could we identify um some major
principles which are non-negotiable for
sustainability and then train over those
and see to that companies local
authorities and whatever do the same put
on all the details so that they don't
violate the overall rules now we must
face what
it's a closed system with regard to
matter and you know what we do is that
we invite the heads of companies and
heads of local authorities together with
middle managers and we train them one
full day and then they have a chorus
book and then we train them for two more
days
heads of major big companies lose weight
and international ones like IKEA and
Electrolux and so forth so they take
this course together with our major
heads and after that they are trained to
train their employees so the trainer
goes home and train their employees and
this is what what they are trained with
this is the training material for the
heads and they have the same pictures
that I'm showing you now when they train
their employees so I don't show you this
to teach you anything I show you this to
give you the pedagogics of what the the
hands on Swedish companies and local
authorities get and then when they go
home they find it a little bit
embarrassing in the beginning to talk
about thermodynamics and cellular
biology because they have forgotten
school and one day a book and two more
days is a little bit little in the
beginning so they then have a video to
make the lecture and then they have a
training material with problems for
their employees so the employees are
going to solve problems together based
on the system thinking that project
which I just described moving into the
new house how do you do it in business
and then the rules and all that is on
the trunk and the branches and then we
have also written an encyclopedia about
the leaves so scientists for the
environment and also written an
encyclopedia for those teachers so they
can go home and look up all the leaves
in the tree as well and this is written
based on the system conditions I think
that that will do so far we just tell
them about thermodynamics in this closed
system which enters energy and what
energy can do in it and we have a
metaphor and putting down in a big box
with walls around it and you have all
the natural resources in the box
and you put them down and you close it
and you isolate it and you ask the
business leaders what do you think would
happen in the box and they start to
think and then you ask how many are you
dare to open it off the 2000 year and
look down into what it would look like
and they get an intuitive feeling that
it doesn't gain weight nor does it lose
weight but its contacts is a bloody mess
of no value they understand that and
they can work their minds to it because
they understand when they eat and the
seeds on the fields they have when they
have used the forest they have because
the Sun doesn't allow anymore forests
and if they put lamps on the forest to
make it grow and they use water from a
pond to run electricity through the
lamps they understand that when the
water is in the bottom of the box it is
and the sound doesn't lift it up began
now they start running fuel biofuel from
the forest and they figure out if we run
electricity device with fuel from the
forest that will grow less forest that
we have to burn because there are losses
on the way and suddenly they start to
remember things from school which is
relevant to this big box and in their
eyes in the eyes of the elves in the box
they would experience all this as being
materialistic bills as dispersed
worthless matter because everything has
a tendency to disperse and at the
beginning we go don't we don't talk
about that as the second law of
thermodynamics we just give them a lot
of examples of why they tidy up on
Fridays because you know a mess have a
tendency to appear spontaneously and and
this is why they have to polish their
car to prevent it from dispersing but no
matter how they punish it will
eventually spread into a cloud of rust
and they know that it's just a matter of
time however nothing disappears and this
is news to most of them including the
major politicians in the swedish
parliament they think that things
disappear they think that when a
gasoline tank is empty the gas has
disappeared and you have to take some
time to tell them that it their
realization of your comprehension of the
world or reality is due to the fact that
is disperses so every atom in the
gasoline is still there but
a dispersed problem sort of shape you
know as a bill to be paid disbursed junk
instead of concentrated structured value
so they understand after this after
having given them enough metaphors that
the only thing that can be produced or
consumed is values or quality and
quantity is always constituted by
concentration and structure which can be
measured in xyg analysis and information
value analysis as this matter and energy
cannot disappear you can regard the
company as a box what comes in must come
out do we consume more quality regarded
as concentration structure than we allow
to rebuild either by ourselves or
together with nature because it's the
whole box we look at and then we make
them understand that the only true
primary production unit we have a
quality here is the green cell which is
good for them and it's new but they have
it in their tummy they understand that
when you talk about it they have had it
in that stomach since they were children
but they're just not had an intellectual
language to understand why we need the
green cells so then we introduce the
cell and explain to them how it is a
cosmos of life events and how
complicated it is and how they
completely dominate the quality on earth
and that they are the primary production
units which is also called primary
production the photosynthesis all other
productions is secondary to that one for
instance the metabolism in our cells
which consume quality because we do not
feel directly by the Sun and they I can
see that we are fueled by something
which is fueled by the Sun namely those
or indirectly a cow which is fueled from
them but since we are not directly
fueled by the Sun we have to dissolve
matter into dispersed junk which they
can visualize and but the bills are paid
because sound driven water cycles the
wind cycles bring the dispersed junk
back to them and rebuild the quality and
therefore
we exist because they exist and this
makes it possible to draw a little first
outline of the nature cycles where the
Sun side of it all through the plant
cells have the primary production or
quantity all other production is
secondary to that and consume more
quantity than is produced if you measure
it as actually and they can understand
and see that however as long as the
bills are paid for we and one other
secondary production add quality because
quality is not only exigent it is also
information value so as long as our
bills are paid for by the plant cells we
add value to nature and don't have to
look upon ourselves as a burden to eat
the world and this is good for them too
and then we give them the geophysical
cycles which are on thousands or
millions of years some of them and tell
them how the deposits in the earth crust
is also generated from the cycles on top
of earth which gives them a
comprehension of how it alls evolves in
this kind of everything ology or what
you wherever you would call it that we
can have a time axis where each part
here is 1 billion years and the first
cell came up to 1 billion years and E
and it looked exactly like the end stage
in the Box by that time because there
was nothing there to collect concentrate
and structure values so it was a
dispersed giant and the first cell came
about which has made many cellular
biologist deeply religious some of them
crazy but most of them quit thinking
about how it could evolve against the
second law of thermodynamics we have
very very cheap models to understand how
it occurred anyway it did some fueled
cells to divide and concentrate and
structure value with dispersed yarn as
building blocks what happens of the
billions of years when that has gone on
the natural resources evolved and it
becomes cleaner and cleaner between the
natural resources since disperse junk is
constant
and structures so what is here the
poisonous sulfur is compound is here a
salt bridge between two amino acids in a
Cell meaningful instead of poisons and
then comes the animal cells the
dinosaurs or whatever and you get the
idea now comes man and we have added
value and we have added culture and
knowledge and everything in a wonderful
history and also sometimes very sad of
course and dramatic but it has been
overall sustainable at least to the
extent that we are here today and talk
to one another and this makes it
possible for us to draw a short of
sustainability seen as a flow diagram of
quality and they understand that it is
quality which we are reusing again you
recognize how the sustainable IKEA or
Electrolux or local government must
integrate itself in the whole system
where the cyclic processes build quality
for them they can't live hanging loose
in the air like today's economy thinks
it must be integrated living from the
continuous import of quality and the
business leaders understand at this
point that they don't they can't even
consume water because the motor
molecules don't disappear what is it
they're consuming them this matter
cannot disappear each molecule they
drink leave their body what is it it is
the quality cleaners which is a
potential difference between dirty water
and clean water and the water that
leaves their body is dirty but the Sun
shines on it the green cells make
carrots and salad from it and again the
water is clean and they can see now that
we don't consume what matter or energy
we consume it's quality and we must live
from importing quality which was non
quality was this disparate junk but now
it is wood and wool and cotton and all
that and they keep whatever they are
buying and purchasing in this company
and downstream they have to emit on the
actor as much chart back to nature the
atoms are still there but the quality is
consumed with less structure and
actually and less information value
for nature to rebuild its quantity again
we also recycle minerals based on this
model you can identify again actually
four system conditions for
sustainability which are non-negotiable
which are intellectual intact solid and
which are easy to understand the first
is that when Electrolux and the world us
or Sweden has moved into this new
sustainable house
we have quit living from the poses in
the earth crust we namely the reason is
that we cannot mine more than it takes
nature to deposit back into the earth
crust because since everything spreads
in such case we will drown in junk from
the Earth's crust so every grab mercury
that we mined we land up in the
dispersed shape in nature sooner or
later even if we recycle 95% of the
batteries 5% in each cycle goes out in
nature and it will cause increase every
ever continuing increases of
concentration overall in the box where
we live and they understand that and by
visualize that it means that if they
want to do something about that it is
not sufficient to buy a recycling device
for metals unless you link that to a
decrease of mining if you don't link it
upstream to what was the intention of it
it is not no help for nature and this
but this is done all over they buy those
recycling things but they don't audit it
upstream to what was the intention of it
and they don't because they don't see
this they think that the cyclic Society
and I tell you in spite of all the
Arctic as you write and all that they
still believe that the cyclic side
Society is something with returned
bottles the technical side is you know
and if you if you can't put your own
enterprise in a box for return bottles
the cyclic principle is probably
something which has got to do with
somebody else you know this is what they
think the second system condition which
is as non-negotiable is that when we
have moved into our new house we have
quit producing
producing molecular garbage and visible
garbage to a higher extent than nature
can recycle it into new quality and it
means that by that time we have quit
completely phased out or persistent our
natural compounds PCB Didit e diagram
Freeman's all that and the third is of
course linked with our next
interrelationship to the living systems
or to the environment we cannot harvest
more from nature than it nature can
rebuild we can take out more fish we can
take more forestry that is rebuilt we
can't put asphalt on those services and
why can't we do that because they pay
our bills so if we poison these systems
with carbon dioxide which is which is in
this context a molecular garbage in
spite of that it is a building block for
life because it is left over and
steadily increase if we continue to do
also with sulfurous compounds false
faults heavy metals freons
PCB DDT diagrams anti flammables
at the same time as we take away the
productive surfaces physically that pay
the bills for us they can see how we are
destroying the branch we're sitting on
from several positions in the same time
now the fourth system condition of
course is then about this flow within
those boundaries one two three we have
to succeed in implementing an efficient
and just economy on the whole in the
whole box and it is not efficient than
just if 1 billion people storm from a
medical point of view because they do
and 1 billion people have an
overproduction of plastic ducts this is
not efficient and just metabolized all
the resources within those boundaries
and they understand they would rather
earn money from doing something good for
people with as few resources as possible
they're doing bad things with a lot of
resources I still feel that they are
going to work and our money from it and
there's no problem to explain this
they don't refuse at this point either
surprising at this might be however our
present unsustainable society functions
like this we violate all those
conditions which leads to a
ever-increasing buildup of garbage and
molecular garbage and there are ten
times more molecular garbage than
visible garbage and it stays in the same
box and the molecular garbage now
function as what you call it gives what
is that more dirt in a machinery and the
concentrations continue to increase
increase you know and this is very easy
to visualize for them because if you
have a big bathtub and you take an INT
and you put one drop of ink in it and
after one you don't see it anymore and
you ask the industry leaders do you
think it has disappeared
and they no no no they you know they
want to show they really really
comprehend it hasn't disappeared and
then we tell them if you do it all over
again and the bathtub turns slight light
blue would anyone become surprised no no
no they wouldn't be surprised but but
they are before this lesson because
polar bears see their purpose with milk
containing anti flammables and the whole
society gets surprised you know but
matter cannot disappear but it disperses
how could it be otherwise if we allow
ourselves to produce those those
compounds now we started to say that we
are intelligent as individuals we can
visualize this even males can see it all
in the same time and draw conclusions
from it and you want to turn off the
tabs of string instead of just doing
things amongst the leaves but what do we
do together this is so simple for a
single brain but what do we do together
we send out scientists with Manish
blinders amongst the leaves and the
society asked them the same stupid
question over and over again is the
threshold for damage already exceeded
for your molecule and the green how
special is the carbon dioxide you know
especially say yes some of them the
greenhouse effect is all
here and the ice storms of Florida and
the ever-increasing amplitudes of
hurricanes tell us this and the other
scientists no no no no no we can still
take much more of carbon dioxide and
then we ask the same question to cadmium
specialists have the threshold for CAD
for kidney disease in people already
happened and some of them say for
instance the people in Belgium the
scientists they say yes and the Swedish
scientists say no no no it's probably
something else while it all is
increasing since the cyclic function
does not cyclic principle does not work
due to violation of the fourth principle
if if a single individual would be that
dumb it would be like a housewife named
moody Svea
Buddhist Thea is named for Sweden and we
call this housewife extremely silly
housewife move - Rhea in this case she
comes home to a flooded kitchen and
there is not one tap on the four taps
and therefore the water cannot go in the
cyclic system because it can't take the
time this overflowing so it goes down
and goes down to the floor
so her kitchen is flooded what does she
do in this situation you know what you
would do all of you you turn them off
upstream but she doesn't she's too dumb
she stands like this I wonder where the
water will sneak out first if it will be
in the dining room or into the kid no
into the hall or into the kids
children's because that depends on the
function of the channels the higher
threshold the longer it will stay in the
kitchen see she figures but then
provided that the joints of the
treasures keep the water in and now she
starts to become hesitant about the
function of the door all of those
channels so she oh she founds up
treasure specialists and austin-ji while
the water is still you know flashing
down the water on the on the on the
floor and she founds out that they
quarrel about this they fight about it
some of them believe that they can take
the water all the way up to the surface
and some of them say no it will start
leaking in the joints so she get a
little bit hesitant and start to ask
ecologists about the damage in other
rooms that is flow
specialists and they fight now she's so
dumb at this point that she feels
comfort that they don't agree upon that
it is going to hell already in her house
while the problem is increasing but she
doesn't have to ask scientists about
everything because she's worked on her
feet and you know acidity causes action
asked my going up it looks strange on
the bottoms of your summer house in
comparison what it looked like when you
were young and all that you had don't
have to ask anyone so what does she do
in this respect
she needs down take towels and start to
dry without asking yourself then what
because soon all towels are wet these
are all the way the waste deposits
garbage dumps filter deposits which just
increase and nobody else why I mean when
does an individual become smarter than
that two three years of age if you take
an infant no it's true I mean we've got
a system perception put put young being
of that age and threw a stone over its
head so it hits the wall behind the kid
before this age we are completely drawn
or recruited into the effects long down
the cause-effect chain so a child before
that age you know something is sound and
go up there and see what it was you know
and you see this stone rolling that but
above that age they look upstream if it
hit here
somebody must have thrown it in that
direction where did it come from and
what was the purpose with the next stone
hit me and so forth you know now we have
all the scientists you know oh what
about the seals and now we have here the
authors don't feel bad but don't they
feel better while the problem is
increasing behind our back and if we
started to function as a group as
intelligently as it is in your brains
the decision-makers would shout to the
scientists how is it out there amongst
the leaves and they were also back like
in your brains it's hell out here for
system conditions upstream cause and
every study
increase a molecule or garbage where we
are and they would also that sounds
horrifying so we will turn off the taps
that but there is a problem due to the
economic assist and we need to know what
is most dangerous so that we can do the
right thing in the right moment and they
would also the worst thing is that we
are fighting all the time about that and
then the decision makers would be even
even more worried to turn off the tabs
because there is no security in the
system they are out of control so what
we do is that we train those good
examples listening to us those companies
to become good examples and we coach
them by helping them to merge ecology
and economics and we do it by helping
them to apply the for system conditions
in a chance checklist for whatever they
do all measures must be checked upstream
to the very source of the problem
however could how else could they reach
this level meanwhile we help them to
become strong from it because if the
good guys continuously invest in sound
business and become poor from it because
they do the wrong move in the wrong
moment we will systematically cause the
good guys to become poor and the bad
guys to become stronger economically and
therefore we must coach them together
with the economists for the environment
of course
comprehending the same concept to do the
savings to see the investments which
will pay off soon in order to be able to
do the long term investments along the
line while they fill in the crosses on
this chart and we should we help them to
improve their image as well by handing
over prices in Swedish TV with the king
and all that as you can see how it
tortures and then we put the ecology and
economy together in in exactly the same
charge so that the business leader up
there when he does his short-term
measures see to that they don't violate
his possibility to read
a food integration in those four system
conditions now I would just would like
to - yes for two minutes in two minutes
I'm just going to repeat what I've said
and then we have an open discussion
because I would like to repeat it so you
have the whole image of the whole lesson
on one single chart nature functions
like would be quality machine we tell
them where the green cell is the primary
production unit and the animal cell
consumes the xyg quality but it is
reprocessed back into new quantity and
this part of the diagram is sun driven
integrated in this is the progressive
business leaders business or enterprise
in a few years living from an continuous
import of quantity from nature and
export back of non quantity and he tries
to save quality by recycling as much as
possible but a lot of other things along
those lines of the for system conditions
but we do not only recycle what we get
from nature we recycle minerals from the
earth crust as well and when we have
moved into our new house we can allow
ourselves to do that a lot but we must
be extremely cautious so that we don't
let too much rust away of metals and
other things from the earth crust
because the redeposit is so slow however
we can balance that flow we can take
also here we can mine as much as can be
really positive which is virtually
almost zero in comparison to what we're
doing today and that was system
condition number one - was that we must
not omit persistent are natural
compounds 3 we must not systematically
violate the physical conditions not only
the chemical ones but the physical
conditions for the system which pays the
bill for us and within these boundaries
we must succeed to implement an
ever-increasing efficiency in a just
economy
and relate the efficiency to true human
needs which includes the rest of the
nature and they get the idea at this
point we don't do that we violate them
all and therefore we must undertake
measures to change that and I will
finish off by just giving you one
example how it functions one concrete
model I overheard an economist and an
ecologist at the local authority both
having had this exercise for three days
with an interval for book studies in
between and they appeared as an
intelligent team using the same solid
structure when they talk to one another
and this is how it sounded like this is
also part of my new book now coming in
September this is one of the examples
the ecologist we have started to design
a new what do you call those heating
devices he heating plants for a local
authority distant heating plant where
you can provide heat to the houses were
recording energy plant a heating plant
distant heating plant B oh I see but but
we can alright but we can increase
efficiency tremendously by using them
and you can use biofuel and whatever but
but you'll just see how it sounds we
have started to project such a thing
being run on nature gas the ecology say
and the economists say which they always
do why and so he looked skeptical you
know and I've got a little bit afraid
god hasn't he understood anything but he
says the following doesn't nature gas
come from the Earth's crust doesn't that
violate system condition number one is
there any future in it and the ecologist
say yeah we have thought about that so
already at the planning stage we are
going to build it today making it
possible to convert it to by a few would
later on he says so we it's just one of
the crosses along this line which is
exactly how you should use it but the
economist goes on and say why
couldn't you skip the nature gas down
and go directly to buy a few more and
the ecologist say well you economists
always get so damn annoyed when we
suggest that because the prices for
biofuel is much higher than nature gas
in Sweden today and the economies say
for how long considering this because
this is like a funnel mankind is running
into a funnel where the walls are those
system conditions the prices will not be
like that how much does it cost to
convert in relation to build it right
from the beginning and run it with a
high price please don't do anything I
must count on it before and you know
then the environmental movement can go
home and take beer or whatever because
now intelligent people in their fields
of expertise talk over the same system
conditions and this was exactly what we
intended and I have several such
dialogues and I've sent it over to them
for acceptance and they say yeah this is
what happens so it is a book about the
good result but coming out using this
now and that's all so now open for
dialogue we have another 20 minutes oh
is that what you wanted I would prefer
to take it directly because I would like
to just pour also and maybe we could if
we only have quoted on we could have a
joint thing together isn't that okay
Paul this is how I got adjusted
this is this is not how they are defined
this is an interpretation of the four
system conditions to any entrepreneur or
company in a checklist but the first one
is low enough concentrations of
compounds from the Earth's crust this is
an absolute non-negotiable rule for
nature
the second is low enough concentrations
of persistent are natural compounds the
third is maintained productivity and
diversity of nature the fourth is just
and efficient economy or metabolism or
resources energy and all other resources
and this is how they can check
themselves to fulfilment of integration
in the net in the cycles of nature
however if you recall the index systems
this the life cycle analysis are stuffed
with what is allergenic toxic their bio
accumulative and whatever which is only
an index system of trying to figure out
today's impact in the system but it
doesn't give you any security whatsoever
in the changing process so you are not
in control if you live from life cycle
analysis however if you combine life
cycle analysis and such monitor systems
with this it is good and this is one of
the advantages with it it is solid
intellectually you can audit yourself
mathematically towards fulfillment of
the four system conditions which we do
together with scientists for the
environment and it is easy and
attractive to learn it's easy to
understand so the leader of the company
is not completely how to to rely on
specialists with the language it doesn't
understand the whole company understand
the same thing and talk about it
secondly you have a time axis here
which makes you their look on how tough
it will be because there are so much to
do and without the time axes people say
that you are a fundamentalist and
Ayatollah an idiot but if you introduce
the time axis you dare to look at the
gold and if you don't dare to look at
the gold how can you ever reach it
finally you put in your measures here
and you will profit from it immediately
not only when we have reached the goal
because what happens here is
non-negotiable it is the follow and the
ones who do this systematically already
make very good profit from it if they do
the right thing in the right move it's
also wonderful way of communicating to
your customers do you remember that we
promised to do this look here we've done
it now we are doing this next year we
are going to do this and some of these
companies use it directly as a marketing
device this is all we are going to do we
are going to integrate the whole
business into the cycles of nature this
is what we've already done this is what
we're doing and then people feed those
we want to support because no one is a
dumb that he thinks that it can be done
with one leap overnight you know yes
yes they are doing that but so far the
last report has been on traditional
lifecycle analysis in such monitoring
but that is now more and more abandoned
by the companies we are working with
they are now using this for auditing so
I hope that they will start publishing
that too but it's too early it would be
next year the first chance of that
Swedish McDonald's IKEA nectar of those
companies 20 of those
yeah okay eta is the biggest I mean
right playing down that was the first
example was local authority this is iike
this is the largest supermarket chain in
Sweden they run into the final funnel
just recently hit the wall boom and this
is much more expensive in comparison
with investing yourself into that
adaptation of the funnel but they hit
the wall both how did it appear hard
films were stuffed into their
refrigerators and customers started to
ask questions about it and I was meeting
in Copenhagen as you recall a couple of
years ago where we wonder if it was too
late to face it out and the poem has
decided to have a deadline for
production and they felt you know the
funnel coming for this particular
compound so they found up Electrolux and
said we would like to buy some other
kind of stuff to put in our
refrigerators and Electric said we're
sorry but it is your device is married
to hard freons how much will it cost
them well how many refrigerators do you
have in your shops and they got the
number and they calculated well it's 1
billion Swedish crowns you know it's
completely merciless when you hit the
wall you know there is no Security
Council there to take the bump for you
if you plan against the laws of nature
because they are on top of all manmade
groups you know and they hit you one way
or another legislation or whatever but
this is how it looked to them so they
said to Electrolux what is it you
suggest that we buy that well this
device is based on soft fuels they said
happily and the chairman of iike said
does that violate system condition
number 2 and the lay clerk said system
what because they hadn't got that
education by that time but they soon got
it I'll tell you the story Iike said we
would not like to make that affair on
this point we must have a sermon or
together we are not to step when we make
the affair so they did and I did this
but when you have reached this point
never ever tell the specialists amongst
their leaves how to handle the probe
just give him the compass I said the
world is free and the Chairman stood on
his feet and said to Electrolux could
you now please answer the question if
soft fuels which you want us to buy
violating system condition number two a
lot well it's that's not the point he
said after a while you know he looked a
little bit that's not the point the
point is that there is less chloride on
the molecule and it is chloride which
hurts the ozone layer and it follows the
following logistics please please
this is not what I wanted to know I just
want to know if it violates system
condition number two or not is it a
persistent unnatural compound that will
build up or isn't it well it's it's
unnatural and it's good quality on the
molecule so it will build up in
concentrations and then he said yeah but
you have to have tight technical systems
and he said like with hard free ones you
know they are not stupid did they start
to talk like that
you mean like with the hard films yeah
yeah well that will be a buildup my next
question how long can it accumulate
before it hit it's because I don't want
to make the same mistake once again and
that was silence and why was it silent
because when anything accumulates it is
impossible to foresee its special jutsu
complexity and time delay beckon and so
it was silence then he got mad he
displayed his anger in an open session
and so do you want to tell me that you
want me to buy for 1 billion crowd
something which I only know one thing it
is doomed and you can't tell me the time
span the lifespan the expect life
expectancy of this investment and it was
silence I say thank you now we know at
least what we should not and then they
sent out people you know Greenpeace in
the same time through of shaft of
refrigerators outside the main office of
electric so they were very shaken at
this point they lost this 1 billion
Crown Affair and Greenpeace with Aaron
and you know made them even more war
so now they fold us up because we didn't
say anything about you
affair we keep our hands clean from that
just give them an instrument of it
they phoned us up and said could you
please come to our head office and
explain all those system conditions and
molecular garbage and all that junk also
to our think-tank the board the
president everyone so they connected the
whole damn stuff there and we were
invited and we did the same thing and
stopped here don't tell them how to make
refrigerators they're our world's
leaders at least in the minds of Swede
they beat the Unreal electric there and
all the other anyhow the head of
technical development stood on his feet
and said now I'm going to teach you
something that you don't know about
refrigerators and he wanted to put me at
amongst the leaves and he did he said we
use soft fuels to blow the isolation
device of the field rages this
particular technique makes our
refrigerator is better isolated and any
component on the market since they are
better isolated they take less energy to
keep cold and energy is today on a
global scenario produced by violation of
system condition on the world that you
call it he said through a better
efficiency it goes down in direct and
cause beneficial effects on system error
number one which in turn causes a lot of
relief on the greenhouse gas problem
oh I said that's good so you mean by
violating system condition number two
you benefit on system condition number
one yeah yeah there is a trick he says
and this is extremely important what
comes now because there are always not
almost always always contradictions
amongst the leaves if you don't see no
this is what he said when we produce
refrigerator the impact is relatively
small because we only produce it once
after that day it consumes energy day
out a and we
years so by violation of system
condition number two related we benefit
a lot on system conditional well I said
that you can prove on a lifecycle
analysis and I'm so happy to hear it
and you are in control them very nice
congratulations and then what you know
then what because you see the time axis
here and he said what do you mean there
what yeah well when Electrolux has moved
into his new house you don't violate
system condition number two either what
is it in today's planning that makes it
easier to face outs or three walls
tomorrow and that was silence again
and then he said do you think it's easy
to make refrigerators and I apologize
for this impression of my talk and I
only said that this is the funnel and it
is not invented by me or Greenpeace or
anybody the laws of nature is the
generous fundament for our existence and
our economy this is how it is and you
will be phased out if you don't follow I
don't know what to do I'm sorry I'm just
a medical doctor - two weeks later on
they had filled in a complete chart
including all other things as well
including recycling of the minerals for
production of the of the refrigerators
they move from r134a which doesn't have
any chlorine on it at all which solves
the acute problem amongst the leaves he
says on the phone to me but it still
violated system condition of the tool
but it functions as one of those crosses
because it fits the same technology as
purple on the table which is a solution
of tomorrow's electrodes now you
probably want to know he said to me
while we don't move to propose it on
immediately but the reason is that it is
explosive and if we use apply the wrong
technology and it explodes in the face
of the customer we haven't speeded up
this process as you might well
understand
and I told them if you if you put that
in advertisements tell the Swedish
public that you are going through r134a
to propel the tone solutions you will
get our prize and they immediately put
it all over and we handed the prize over
in Swedish television so they wrote the
contract with the Swedish public this is
what we're going to do and it didn't
take them one year to move from r134a to
propound at all and immediately phased
out the heart fields because they are
the plant they saw the future and they
could move down from the leaves and
enter the trunk and approaches but I
have a book of those exams and those
dialogues and whatever somebody must
help me now because yes I have according
to my watch
three minutes short questions and short
answers
[Music]
this very nice thing to say but you know
those people not elect to look some
whatever they know lot more about
thermodynamics and exigent than I do but
the point is they have never drawn the
conclusion what happened when you merge
is that with biology economy and the
social structure and it is the merging
business which we can only do in a
transdisciplinary approach
yeah well when it is a very very
important question because when we when
Electrolux has reached this point the
whole society as such must also reach it
which in turn influences Electrolux so
it is very good for Electrolux to know
what parts the society look like when
the whole society has fulfilled it then
it looks like this I've just drew now I
only have half a minute here we have the
main office and what you call the main
main office or the HQ headquarters sorry
now headquarters or a main city or
whatever you know a central stop and
then in tomorrow's Society it says its
concept if it if it likes to export to
China making refrigerators according to
the Electrolux model and China does not
mind to make it they take old
refrigerators and make new ones from it
on spot and they benefit from it on a
local ground they earn money from it and
they sell the concept and they checked
with modern information technology
quality and everything because at the
time when the whole society fulfills
this there is no way that we continue
with fossil fuels of course now how much
how is the surface to produce only the
private cars today with energy if we go
for instance to biofuel well in Sweden
the total sum of the agricultural
surface will not do even for the private
cars so there will be heavy changes
along that line Herman Daly has told a
joke about it to remember this society
McDonald's does like this already and
now they are really improving on it they
have that concept you know you buy a
hamburger
they don't export them frozen from
Washington or something they you have
the local deals everywhere
anyhow Herman Daly says the Americans
lap cook is an important from Denmark
the Danish people are cook is an
important from USA
why don't they switch recipes this is an
exchange of recipes society that we are
entering if we are managing to do this
in an attractive way which is system
condition number four first of all that
I think they have built up a sort of
tradition of consensus it is possible
for enemies to enter a room and find out
together what are the mutual standpoint
for the two enemies we have a certain I
think skills for doing that we are
writing our scientific consensus
documents on that basis and draw
conclusions of energy agricultural
systems metal flows the society
whatsoever and former enemies who are
fighting one another in debate or
articles and so forth put their names on
the same radical document for change
because we only go to the nucleus of
knowledge expand as long as we can till
we find the interface of where they
don't agree anymore and then we write a
document about that and give that to the
all the educated business leaders this
concept suffice by itself all those
teachers make tremendous job
could could I take two minutes and then
Paul could you could you give us that
because we would like to proceed we
couldn't stop on till time could you
give us the time and be seated
is that okay with everyone just two
minutes what I did this is the technique
I'm certain that it functions in us too
not only in Sweden I phoned up my
scientific friends and all the others
and said this is the truth I sent out
the first document they found all the
errors in it because the professor
cannot resist the temptation to identify
all the others he send it back and I
wrote 21 versions until they all agreed
on the first document business people
were so happy that scientists had lost
agreed upon something so they paid
enough money to translate it into a
booklet and an audio cassette and sent
it out to every household in Sweden 4.3
million copies this was the first
project we launched you see because they
are starving for somebody to tumour to
to to make joint forces because this is
our lives we're talking about here the
next thing is that when I had that going
I found out amputee entertainers for the
environment and said me and all those
scientists are going to launch a
continuous education at 13 Sweden would
you like to celebrate that on Swedish TV
and here comes an extremely important
thing I think for us if I succeed
and they said yes if you succeed because
who want to take part in a failure but
they said yes if you succeed we would
like to celebrate that in Swedish TV and
did the same with TV me and all those
scientists and the artists are going to
launch
if we succeed could you give us a
broadcasting time on TV to celebrate it
or when it starts I said yes if you
succeed I went to the department of
government for education said the same
and then I approached the king and said
me and all the scientists the government
TV entertainers going to launch would
you melt you like to be the patron of
this event
if we succeed if you succeed
and then I went to the sponsors not
until them I said me and the king so you
take the ones that you think that you
will win because you know them and then
you build up from there instead of going
for the baddest most guys
backwards people that you can identify
because this D zero traditional way and
then you boom the your head into them
instead of going to the good guys and
trying to help one another to do the
good stuff to coach the good example
thank you very much our next speaker is
Paul Hawken who I think you'll find will
follow very beautifully what we've just
heard I think that Paul has been working
for many years in this same terrain in
this country among others actually he is
the author of a book called the ecology
of Commerce as well as three others he's
produced a PBS television series he's
started several businesses including a
company called Smith and Hawk in which
he was wise enough or maybe not so wise
to become the CEO of a number of years
and as quite accomplished in a range of
different things I'm very happy to
welcome you here and as as was said we
will follow the laws of nature and go
use as much time after when we were
planned planning to end is when we as we
took when we started so so Paul will
have plenty of time and space to speak
as well and I'm hoping that'll work out
for everyone so is this gonna be okay
for you up there okay fine thanks no if
it's okay for everybody thank you this
is the first time I've heard
carl-henric repair speak so and you're
gonna notice some overlap and one of the
things that inspires me is that he did a
three-day lecture in an hour and since
I'm at MIT I'm assuming you're real
smart and so we're gonna fly today and
then you can see say stop when they're
going too fast but I don't get to spend
much time with you it's nice to see you
too because I'm very intimidated about
coming to MIT because I expected a
roomful of people to look differently
first I'll it'd be mostly men so it's
nice to see a women here but also it's
nice to see really human faces
which they always are in anyway but I
want to talk about instead of engineers
I want to talk about these dialogue that
the carl-henric mentioned that has not
really occurred it's not well developed
in this culture particularly which is
the dialogue between the two great
systems that dominate our lives which
are natural systems and commercial
systems and and that is why the book is
called the ecology of Commerce and which
is what I'm gonna talk about today there
is no such thing of course which seemed
like a worthy topic to address and from
my experience I didn't come from a
cancer cell it really came from a small
business experience which is trying for
really over 20 years to do this some of
the things that Carl having talked about
and really coming up against repeated
systemic obstacles in business itself
that really prohibited if not inhibited
my ability to be and if you will an
environmental company and it came to a
head I think when we won the Council on
economic priorities stewardship award
environmental stewardship awards the
first time a small company had been
given that award and I realized as I
walked up to the podium George Plimpton
was the master of ceremonies and I was a
sea of black ties and white pearls and
that that what happened is that the the
my readings with Odom's and Awful's and
energetics and Georgescu Brogan and
etcetera had sort of been haunting me
for the years as we became more
environmentally what as our country
became more of an environmental leader
what happened is that my vestigial
education started to haunt me and I
realized that as fast as we were going
that we weren't getting anywhere very
fast at all and in fact that summation
of all our environmental initiatives
when totaled up had very little impact
on the conditions that Carl Heinrich
mentioned and that that was as I said
reached a very bad point when we won the
award because I realized that we didn't
deserve it and the good news
said nobody else deserves it either so I
accepted it but and I had already
actually sold if you will or the idea of
the the ecology of Commerce to my
publisher which was very much a good
news type of book about what we could do
as businesses and then after that I went
back to my publisher and said I can't
really write this book and I wanted to
write something else and which I did and
what I wanted to write about and what I
want to talk about is really the idea of
design it seemed to me at that point
when I realized that if you took the
best practices of the best companies in
and I'm going to speak of the United
States now because I'm more familiar
with those companies but if you took
those practices or take them today and
then you overlay them over the other 80
to 100 million businesses in the world
and there's a lot of companies of the
world most of them small of course but
if you overlay them that the fact the
matter is that the rate of environmental
degradation the rate of natural resource
depletion the rate of dispersal of
molecular garbage is really good not
going to diminish greatly at all that is
not going to have a big impact on our
movement to environmental hell in this
culture so it seemed to me that the good
news was that we didn't have a
management problem after all and that
not to say that we didn't have
uninformed managers of our companies we
do is not that we don't have some bad
managers of course we do it's a human
condition but it seemed to me that what
we had was really a perception and a
design problem in business and that we
didn't have the design tools to look at
the problem together and as Carl
Heinrich has pointed out arguing about
the leaves in a sense basically one of
the great problems in this culture is
environmentalists and I'm one of them I
count myself as one of them have been
extraordinarily effective at basically
defining the problem and sort of coming
literally if not figuratively from the
wilderness into the urban environment
into the corporate environment and says
guess what you have a problem and this
sort of began in the modern era with
Rachel Carson and she inspired a whole
host of people in graduate school and
college to follow her footsteps and so
what happened is that you have seen this
acceleration of the ability
of endocrinologist of wildlife
specialists of biologists of chemists of
all sorts of scientists be able to
really define with enormous specificity
the problems the breadth and depth and
in a sense some of the catastrophic
implications of our production methods
in Congress today the problem with that
is that as environmentalists we have
raised money by scaring the Wits out of
people with our mass mailings and so
forth and in the process not only of
polarized people produce an adversarial
relationship but we haven't really come
and said by the way which is true that
in these problems are some elegant
elegant design solutions that is to say
that by presenting the problems in such
a chicken little Cassandra way we have
in a sense caused I think corporations
of business to sort of look away from
biology as a template as a mentor as a
as a design motif if you will eat
material for us to in a sense reimagine
how it is that we make and how it is
that we process material and so with
that in mind it seemed to me that again
if we take the the leaves if you will to
use Kohana mix metaphor but if we take
the adversaries in any society whether
it's a city whether it's a corporation
whether you know the unions teachers
corporation corporate executives we take
the right wing we take the left wing we
take Baptist and Hindus it doesn't make
any difference but if we get those
people together and we ask them what
kind of world they want to live in 50
years in terms of desired outcome their
children is it a peaceful world how far
do they have to drive to work do they
really want to inhale pollutants or not
do they really want to walk around as
decentralized landfills with 3000 or
natural compounds in their bones in milk
do they really want to live this way or
would they rather live in other ways in
it's remarkable and that is we all
really agree how we want to live 50
years forward and so if you do that and
you back
caste then you have a way of really
looking at the problems today and trying
to come up with solutions that are
consensus based and collaborative as
opposed to adversarial so I took that
upon myself lacking that roomful of
disparate people and it seemed to me
that if we were going to redesign
commerce in a way that was going to be
work that was practical that was
implementable that respected the laws of
natural systems but the same time did
not throw the baby out with the
bathwater recognized that 90-plus and I
don't know what that percent is but 90
plus percent of what corporations and
commerce does it does very well and it's
really that last 10% which it does very
poorly indeed if we're going to redesign
what would we want to do what would be
the design criteria again if we're
moving in this case the metaphor is if
we're going to build a house what it's
going to look like
how are you live in it what's how what
are the functions are going to be and I
came up with some very simple ones which
is number one that if we're going to
have a sustainable restorative system of
Commerce then we in the north and the
OECD industrial nations have to reduce
our throughput of material and energy by
80 percent in the next 40 to 50 years
and there's two or several reasons for
this the first one is we have the
technology to do it right now that is we
don't depend on any breakthroughs not to
say there won't be in order to do that
number two we have to do that because
what's happened in the West is that we
are holding out to the rest of the world
through our nafta's and through our
Ghats and other types of encouragement
on trade policy we're holding out a
model of materialization in other words
a bootstrap and we're saying listen you
can raise yourself up by this bootstrap
just as we did and the fact is this
bootstrap is not attached to a boot it's
only the strap there's no way that the
rest of the world can do what we did
because in order to do so there increase
in terms of the inputs that is the
increase in terms of resource
utilization would go up by a factor of
four to twelve times depending on whose
figures you use in terms of the increase
in
standard of living and increase in the
rate of population so we're talking
about an increase in the impact on
living systems on this planet this
absolutely impossible we already know
from the work of airlock and others at
Stanford and that we're using 40% of net
photosynthetic production and P P of the
on land we actually don't have a real
good fix on it in terms of the ocean but
40% of NPP so just a doubling of
population which is for dam foreordained
is going to double that at that point
you get some real crashes in terms of
species in terms of habitat viability
and that means that there's no change in
standard of living whatsoever if the
rest of the world does change the
standard of living you're talking about
one hundred and sixty percent a two
hundred forty percent utilization of
sunshine net photosynthetic production
every year which of course is impossible
so that reduction in eighty percent
means that we have to in a sense create
a form a method of materialization a
method to create a standard of living
that the rest of the world can replicate
and it's to its favor and not to us
disservice that as they say something
that is viable both for us and for them
and right now we don't have that model
and so therefore all our trade
agreements are inherently corrupt
because they're unachievable absolutely
unachievable in terms of the stated
goals for them the next thing though and
this is where again being one with
faulty environmental community and that
is it's no good talking about the
reduction of throughput unless you also
talk and you have a very practical and
realistic way to increase the quality
level meaning and number of jobs
worldwide otherwise you're just simply
exchanging one problem for another and
to me if you're not talking about jobs
you're not talking about the environment
you're just not serious about the
question because there's two and a half
billion workers in the world today a
third of which you're either unemployed
or cannot
themselves marginal jobs and there are
two billion more workers coming into the
workforce in the next ten years ten
years
it's this I don't know why this isn't
being talked about and the question is
what are they going to do so unless we
have a way of reducing throughput and
increasing meaningful family wage jobs
here and everywhere else in the world
we're not going to solve the
environmental problems the next thing
really is this word sustainability and
I'd like to just say that I will
continue to use it because it's come in
too popular
it's the parlance of the day but really
we do not want to sustain what exists we
have degraded our living systems and
natural systems too far to even
countenance the idea of sustainability
we're talking about restoration we're
talking about economics of restoration
we're talking about economics it
restores and rebuilds and returns
natural systems to states that they were
not so long ago certainly within the
last hundred two hundred years so we're
talking about restoration as a sort of a
idiom as opposed to sustainability the
next thing and I want to say this
guardedly is to respect market
principles what I mean by that in our
paraphrase Chesterton Chesterton when he
said about Christianity but he said
there's nothing wrong with Christianity
says no one's tried it yet and I would
say the same thing about the free market
which is that we haven't really tried it
out in fact I'd go further to say is
that we haven't really tried capitalism
out yet either and capitalism is only
half a loaf right now because it
excludes all of natural capital in its
balance sheet in its accounting in the
way it figures cost-benefit price etc so
what I'm saying is yes let's have a
capitalistic free-market system but only
when it's complete a half a system is no
system at all
and so that means is that when the a
person goes into the marketplace when
they buy the lowest-priced good whether
it's a tomato or an object that they're
doing the best for themselves
economically which is the natural
tendency of human beings for their
community for the people who produce
that product and for the environment and
for generations to come
and in other words that we have embedded
into commerce itself restoration as
opposed to what we have now which is
only the rich can afford to conserve and
if you have discretionary income you can
go into a store of bread and circus or
something and buy higher priced goods
you feel good about yourself and I'm
saying that's absolutely not going to
work that's fine it's good in terms of a
trailblazing effort is to be lauded and
praised but as an economic construction
it's absolutely elitist in its upside
down and backwards it has to be from the
bottom up not from the top down so those
are the criteria and the question is how
do we do that no it was how do we can we
do that is that possible is this some
sort of sort of Arcadian you know pipe
dreaming or have I been smoking
something and I think that these things
rather than appearing to be sort of
distant visionary goals are not only
linked but are actually much more
possible and practical than the course
that we're pursuing right now so I don't
see these as I mentioned as being
opposite or and being opposition to each
other or in being opposition to an
healthy prosperous economy worldwide now
it seems to me that if we're going to do
that we need then design tools we talked
about what the criteria are but what are
the tools what are we going to use and
it seems to me that's fairly obvious
again as Carl Heinrich mentioned the
most productive system that we can
possibly imagine is Maegan tropic it's
the green plant cell when we study green
cells we I can't say that we necessarily
understand them I don't think anybody
can really say that but we do understand
is it when it comes to energetics when
it comes to a system that is so
elegantly efficient there is nothing
that even equals that nothing that we
have done as human beings that even
approximates this elegance in terms of
design and there are some simple
principles and and I will offend every
biologist in the audience when I mention
them because they're oversimplified but
that we can use as in a sense tools or
standards to look at how we redesign and
reimagine cars and the first one is that
there is no waste in nature that isn't
food for other living systems now you
can go right back at me and say well
what about the Carboniferous period and
oil and coal and so forth and get back
to that but basically in a dynamic sense
there is no waste that isn't food or
isn't some form of nutrients for other
systems and this is very important
because what we have in our system is a
industrial linear take make waste system
in which the waste the metabolic waste
of industry is not food for anything at
all there's nothing really the key
needed though is not to say that we
don't eat it we do it's in our food and
deliberately in some cases inadvertently
in many cases actually but the fact of
the matter is that the persistent
bioaccumulative substances that we make
the molecular garbage is not food for
any living system we have not discovered
one yet anyway
and we're trying it on ourselves but I
don't think it's going to succeed as
being food for a living system so the
second principle is we have to run off
current solar income and again I'm not
going to repeat with Karl Heinrich
pointed out which is that in a
closed-loop system the only input on
earth is sunshine and nature does not
run off you know capital reserves it
does mine it doesn't have an X on
working for it and but it's important to
understand that current income in its
various forms current solar income is in
a sense what it creates these highly
efficient metabolic pathways that we see
in nature so the last name of course is
the
it requires diversity enormous
biodiversity in order to do the first
two now if we take those principles and
then we sort of put them up there then
what does commerce look like that
employs those principles as opposed to
the if you will the principles of
industrialism which are the principles
of a sort of purported linear system
that supposes somewhere that there's an
infinite source of natural products of
inputs of air of energy of water of soil
and there's an infinite sink out there
in order to put the metabolic wastes
it's essentially how industrialism was
organized now if you switch that and you
use these criteria then we have to ask
ourselves you know what does commerce
look like what would we how would we
make things how would we drive around
what would we wear what would we eat how
what would our jobs look like what would
our factories look like and the fact
that matter is that when you take those
you start to parallel very similarly and
I as I said I have never heard or seen
this lecture before but you come up to
the same conditions that Carl Heinrich
mentioned and they probably the best
work that's being done in terms of
describing this is probably Michael
Brown guards work in Germany at the EPA
called the intelligent product system
it's a twenty five criteria and I'm not
going to give you all 25 today because
it's pretty exact but it really boils
down to a product typology which is that
if you're going to make things in in
using biology as a sort of practicing as
they working metaphor as a design
template for goods and services then
they're going to fall into three
categories and eventually only to the
first category is consumables the second
category is products of service and the
third category is unsalables now what
Michael means about consumables are what
he's talking about is that a consumable
is something that is food for a living
system that is to say not just food that
we eat but it is when you literally
throw it away
when
disperse it then it becomes food for
microorganisms or some other species and
that is to say with no persistent or bio
cumulative or toxic effects whatsoever
it doesn't disturb that I say that
species or that life-form and now you
would think then that much of what we
have is consumable that is to say for
example we're all wearing clothes it
came from cotton linen silk Ramey
there's all these natural fibers that we
wear and then we pay so much for but
when you actually start to break down
your clothing and you start to find out
what's in it which you find out as
you're getting these natural products
plus there's 7,000 different chemicals
between you and your Calvin's and that's
what it takes to get them on your hips
and most of those chemicals almost all
of them have been invented since World
War 2 the effects of which we do not
understand on living systems only in a
very very specific way the nickel on the
clasp of your jeans 20% of the women in
this culture have nickel Reaction have
nickel allergies that affects their
thinking their memory short-term memory
loss concentration and so forth also
comes from the findings in the earrings
and your costume jewelry but that's on
your zippers and on the class so you
jeans and so forth so this code for
example has 40 grams of lead chromate as
a mordant so forth these shoes also have
led they chromium from tanning they also
have LEDs as a stabilizer and the
polyurethane and the soles of the shoes
and so forth so we can go on and what
happens when we deconstruct what we
should be able to just throw away when
it's done and threadbare and not useful
to anybody else we find that the very
things that we're buying and using and
making there's no place to put them
where am I gonna put this jacket or who
Salvation Army great but then who who is
the final user where are they going to
put it there's no place to put it
there's no metabolic system that we know
of that can eat and metabolize this
jacket and you think that's bad
the tie not only his silk right this is
true for your suck blouses so you women
you can't get away so easily but this
has tin and zinc to make it feel like
expensive silk it's cheap so it doesn't
matter what the layer last right but
also has chrome and molybdenum so
basically what you're wearing all of us
men with our silk ties his basic little
heavy metal deposits so then you can
imagine if you take a truck and you put
our money ties and Reebok shoes and DKNY
blouses right and Ralph polo Blazers and
throw in like 10 televisions by EPA
standards your toxic waste hauler and
you need a permit to go in the highway
so what Michaels talking about in terms
of consumables is if we're not going to
make things if you can literally throw
away and become compost food for living
systems then you have to make it as a
product of service and that's the second
type and what he's saying is if it's not
a natural nutrient then it has to be a
technical nutrient in other words what
he's saying is that you have to make it
in such a way that you take all of it
back when the user is done and we say is
that a product or service like a
refrigerator or a car or television is
something that we want the service we
want entertainment called food we want
to transport ourselves we do not want to
consume it because we can't nobody can
consume a television that contains 4,300
chemicals cadmium mercury lead an
explosive inner vacuum tube Muskaan it's
not consumable so what he's saying is if
you make a product or service in this
typology then you have to make it in
such a way that it has value to you
because you own it forever so if your
General Motors it's your car forever
when the end-user is finally done with
it it comes back to you and you can't
throw it away
there's no landfills in this society
there was no carpet under which anything
may be placed because there isn't any
way and that's Carl Heinrichs point we
can delay the understanding of that we
can pretend it isn't true we can ship
our lead batteries to Nigeria for
recycling and poison people there but
the fact is there's no place to put it
so what happens of course is when you
think of your products as being truly
cyclical as being manufactured within a
closed-loop system which of course they
are then the design criteria changes
dramatically how do you design it in
such a way that when it comes back to
you it has a value and what this is
doing already in Germany in anticipation
of the ver soccer Princip and these
take-back principles which are being
bandied about in Parliament and so forth
is it's producing real engineering
technical breakthroughs hewlett-packard
for example already designs for
disassembly in Germany and discovered
when they design for disassembly that it
saved the assembly cost by assembly time
70% it reduced assembly labor 70% of
course they went back to the engineers
and said well why didn't you do this
earlier and they said you didn't ask you
know didn't ask the question but they're
not just designing for disassembly
they're designing for disassembly and
complete reuse of the materials so
they're going to the plastics
manufacturer BMWs done this are the
companies and saying by the way what's
in this stuff and they give them an
ingredients list they said oh my god I
don't want it back
because if I we melt this plastic it's
useless and I want to breathe what
happens when I melt it anyway it'll
poison my workers so they're becoming it
with new thermoplastic resins which are
not only sulfur-based do not have heavy
metal stabilizers which can be reused 10
20 30 40 times before they start to be
no longer useful so there's time to push
out on this chart the useful life of the
materials that they're doing so that
basically the raw materials for the auto
industry are on the highway today not in
the chrome mines of South Africa you
know not in the Mesabi Range not
Kuwaiti oil fields and the last category
is unsalables and they're saying is if
you still want to make these persistent
toxins heavy metals radio activities
that's fine but just like the products
of service you own them forever you have
to put your name on you have to
molecularly mark them and what they're
talking about here is you know we have
if you look sort of a history of rights
in this country not this country in the
world starting with Magna Carta which is
for rich white men noble rich white men
and then we had the declaration
independence which was for rich white
men and then you know we had the
so-called emancipation proclamation
which didn't really do the job but then
we had suffrage and then of course we
had the civil rights movement which did
a little bit better and then we had of
course the endangered species that we
have the woman's who have excuse me and
then we had the Endangered Species Act
1973 which is the first time that we
recognized that other living beings had
rights as well but you know what we
don't have is the right to biological
privacy so if I lick my finger I have
twenty to thirty chlorinated
hydrocarbons right now on my index
finger and so you buy the right and we
don't know the effects of those unliving
systems in real time generations to come
so what the unsalable category is saying
is that you have to put your name on
your chemicals molecular li mark which
is possible today so that if I go to my
well in my farm in find I bromo chloro
propane in it then I take it to the
county agent say listen could you look
to something find out who it belongs to
and he says all looking that's
Occidental Petroleum it's hooker
chemical there's an 800 number on and I
call it up and say could you come get it
there must be a problem
iein put it there must be yours right so
again we're talking about a cyclical
economy cyclicality implies
responsibility and accountability it
means an accountability is cyclical by
definition so in other words if you want
to make these things that lasts for ten
thousand hundred thousand years so forth
that are toxin toxic for the day they're
made until the day they degrade and then
even further fine but you own them and
you have to take responsibility for them
there's more to that anyway what we're
talking about here again is a
manufacturing system of course that
gives very positive incentives for
people to move away from those those
compounds right now we have these
perverse incentives which is it's really
cheaper for manufacturers to use these
compounds as long as they don't have to
take responsibility for it
so we're not talking about a system that
punishes corporations for what they do
we're trying to talk about a system
they're reimagines it that rewards them
for what they cannot do now and stay
competitive and that's very very
important as I say it's too late in the
20th century in a sense to make people
wrong it's not going to do as any good
whatsoever we have to find a way to make
people right we have to find a way to do
this in a way that does not blame or
excoriate or hold responsible in a way
that produces fear anxiety and doubt in
the commercial world otherwise we're not
going to get there now having talked
about a in a sense a product criteria a
product typology then we also have to
talk about another thing which is
information itself and that is that when
we go out into the marketplace and this
is the so-called free market what money
is what prices are in a and assistants
point of view is information they give
us information and give us a lot of
information and it's a very as a
tremendous amount of complexity in two
four eighty nine and even though it's
highly reductionist and so forth it
actually has a pronounced effect on what
we do and if there is a any democracy
and
in some ways it is the marketplace and
how we shop and how we buy but it
affects businesses as much as consumers
and because it does what we can say in a
sense is that what Carl Heinrich is
talking about what sort of restorative
economy is is a movement a transition
from at least priced to at least cost
economy and that you can understand the
arguments the sort of the adversarial
positions you can understand much of the
disagreement in this context and
basically when you have the argument
what you're talking what you're seeing
is the least price people which is
business who are rewarded and punished
when they stray from Elise product
strategy and you're - and they're
talking to environmentalists and
citizens and so forth we're talking
about a least cost outcome right and
they're trying to have a conversation
with each other and usually the
environmentalists have never you know
written or met a payroll and oftentimes
the people who meet the payroll are
biologically illiterate and so what
we're talking about is trying to create
a conversation or vocabulary a ways to
discuss how to make this transition
because the lease price economy a lease
price system is going to destroy itself
and I don't have to describe that you
know that very well you wouldn't be here
the question is how do we make it to a
lease cost system really and what I mean
by lease cost of course is a natural
capitalistic system a system that takes
into account all of the costs both in
real time and into the future
of what we use what we metabolize and
the waste thereof and a lease cost
system interestingly goes back to
criteria number two which is jobs
remember the beginning I said well you
got to reduce through pus but at the
same time you have to increase
employment what happens when you move
away from an industrial linear take make
waste system to a cyclical closed-loop
away from hydrocarbons to carbohydrates
away from oil soluble to water soil to
water soluble from linear to cyclical we
can go right down the checklist but what
happens is you're moving away from a
system that has valued and made money by
increasing human productivity which is
the present industrial system to one who
has very positive incentives to increase
the productivity of natural systems and
then those incentives are far greater
than the ones of increasing human
productivity the industrial system as we
know it was founded in a sense in a time
when there was relatively few people and
a super abundance of raw material and we
have now reversed that we have a super
abundance of people and a in a
decreasing amount of raw material and
natural resources and yet we're still
using the same principles as if they
still applied and of course they don't
apply whatsoever and what we have to do
in a sense is change the price system so
that all the participants in the economy
five and half billion people get the
right information because as long as
they get the wrong information they're
going to make the wrong choices in
evitable
for example when you talk about
sustainable agriculture versus
industrial agriculture you're talking
about one model which internalizes its
cost and one model which externalizes
its costs I don't need to tell you which
is which the fact is when you
internalize your costs you have a higher
price so you go to the market and your
tomato or your lettuce is more expensive
than the product where costs have been
externalized now those externalized
costs of course are health to the worker
groundwater depletion soil depletion
pesticide runoff the eutrophication of
our lakes and rivers and oceans due to
the runoff of free nitrate now when you
compare them and you go to the market
you say well this is more expensive in
the industrial tomato it's cheaper of
course it's upside-down and backwards
the fact is the organic or sustainable
produce demand was much cheaper than the
one produced industrial except you don't
get that information
marketplace now what's so interesting
about this to me is that the analogy is
to toxicity itself we think of toxins as
poisons there are poisons we don't
necessarily understand how toxins
poisonous the way pesticides and
herbicides poison things is they give
the organism the wrong information
they are hormone replicants that's one
of the problems with them is that we
recognize in our body as hormones which
is why they cause endocrine disruption
cancer etc but the fact of the matter is
that a broad leaf recognizes an
herbicide as a growth hormone it makes
it grow so quickly it outstrips its
capacity to take up water nutrients and
it dies and we say oh it's a toxin it
killed it it didn't kill it it made it
grow so fast it killed itself so we can
look at our price system is basically
the same thing it's a toxic information
is giving us the wrong signal
we are outstripping our capacity to take
up nutrients and so forth and we are
going to kill ourselves and a lot of
things with us so when we're talking
about moving from a least price to a
least cost system we're and it's not
we're not talking about an academic
exercise we're not talking about
economics we're talking about how do you
give people the right information so
that they naturally make the right
decisions and how do you do that in such
a way that you don't lower their real
income which is extremely important
because if you lower their real income
they'll reject it so you have to do it
in a revenue-neutral way which is why
and the and I think Sweden will be the
first country to do this but you have to
absolutely remove the taxes on people
all taxes on people all income taxes all
social security medicare everything the
taxes a human being get rid of it
because what happens now is we have an
industrial system that not only devalues
nature of it devalues people with
getting rid of people we're downsizing
we're restructuring all these euphemisms
but basically we're getting rid of
people very rapidly producing this
tremendous anxiety in the workforce and
social dislocation what we want to do is
do the opposite
and when you shift the tax system from
people and you shift it to energy too
virgin resources to those things we want
to preserve and save then you produce
incentives for companies to increase the
productivity of their natural capital
and those incentives when you increase
the in the efficiency and the
productivity of natural capital you
require more people to do it if you
compare the labor intensity of the
Carboniferous or the non-renewable
energy systems as compared to renewable
renewable energy systems are 2 to 5
times more labor intensive and yet they
reduce dramatically the impact we have
on natural resources and you go right
down the line in terms of agriculture
the built environment forestry farming
what happens is when you shift the cost
to natural systems to natural capital
then the incentives are such that you
need more people to make money isn't
that interesting
instead of less so what we're talking
about here is not just saving species or
saving natural resources or preserving
for us cover we're actually talking
about an economy that is the new
Industrial Revolution because it in
itself
will increase the amount and quality of
employment while it decreases the impact
on natural systems the first two
criteria and this is what we have to do
and this is what's waiting for us this
is the economy that we are on the
threshold of and this is the economy
we're kicking and fighting and shooting
ourselves in the foot about every day
and trying to resist because too often
the idea of going you know we talk about
natural fibres people think about hair
shirts they're talking about an economy
that runs you know on current solar
income and they look backwards to Little
House on the Prairie instead of a head
to an economy that's extraordinarily
efficient and elegantly designed and
this is what we have to do
this is what we have to convince not
only ourselves but business this is the
economy that lies ahead and the fact is
that in an if if you have a linear
system we know it's inefficient where
does it show up if you look at
industrialism it's so massively
inefficient that it's staggers
imagination only 1% of the pesticides
four and a half billion pounds a year
actually kill the insects right only 1%
only 2% of the energy used in automobile
transports the person in the car
fourteen point six billion tons of
hazardous waste material are thrown away
every year in the United States
according to the National Academy of
Engineering 93% of the material used by
industry does not go into the final
product 80% of the things we make are
thrown away after one use if you talk
about an incandescent light bulb fired
by a nuclear power plant the nuclear
power plant is only thirty percent
efficient the light bulb is only ten
percent efficient it's really a space
heater
it gives a little light of course
talking about a three percent
utilization of energy and a screw in
light bulb a nuclear power plant so what
we're looking at when we talk about a
restorative and sustainable economy is
an economy that does what industry
promised which is create efficiency and
the opportunity that is before us is to
extract if you will this inefficiency
there's massive inefficiency that is in
the economy today and we can start doing
that right now we don't need new taxes
we don't need new politicians we do need
new politicians but we don't require
them in order to do that now because the
inefficiencies are so overwhelming and
so massive and so it's important that at
the same time where we do act we do need
some structural changes to our tax
system into our legislative system but
the fact is that every company every
city particularly every region every
state every institution
can start to do things today that
basically transform and start to take
advantage of that let me give you just a
couple quick examples of what we're
doing today so you have a sort of
hands-on example as opposed to a
theoretical one is that we are working
in a city in America two cities now that
have hot summers cold winters and what
we're doing is working with a major
manufacturer of super Windows there are
eight or ten which are usually more
efficient in people's walls to build
factories in the cities themselves and
to install windows directly to retrofit
all of or most of all the residences and
business structures in that city now the
calculations are fairly simple although
they're still being done in modeled at
Carnegie Mellon which is this which is
that the number of kilowatt hours is
being exported out the windows is
greater than the cost of the windows on
an amortized basis is that simple in
other words it's cheaper to put in the
windows than to keep buying the energy
from wherever it's coming from and so
what happens is when you put in a window
company and we're calling a window
utility as a working title but what
happens is and you install them the way
it works is that somebody knocks on your
door you know comes and says this will
match these windows exactly but there'll
be super windows whether the wood or
aluminum all the windows are recycled
and reused so if nothing is thrown away
the new wood frame windows are extruded
with recycled thermoplastic resins and
so forth to match exactly the windows
that you have now if you have a
Victorian with oval windows whatever
using a system design at the University
of Minnesota which is an extrusion
process so the windows can be matched
exactly you don't need to change the
architecture of your house now these are
installed you get a check for $500 now
what happens is the city finances the
windows of Industrial Development bonds
that are low interest so it creates
currency in the first unit of
sovereignty that we have which is our
cities villages towns
basically those windows are paid over 20
years in your utility bill and the debt
goes with the structure not with you and
the calculations are done and shown so
that basically is going to cost less to
buy the windows than it was to buy the
heating and quilt that you were
utilizing before so basically you'll
have money in your pocket the city now
has a multiplier effect of the money
being spent in the city now on windows
labor and so forth and being exported
out on the power lines or gas lines so
it's a win-win there's we we count of 30
wins in this cycle right and it's not a
cyclical economy unless it's a win/win
this can be a curved line but it's not a
cyclical economy unless it's win-win one
other area we're working in is in a area
that's very biologically rich and timber
fish and soil but in Washington state
which has the lowest is the lowest 10
percentile in terms of income education
highest 10 percentile in alcoholism
abuse divorce and dropout so what's
wrong with this picture
why are biologically rich places being
duress and in the way they are but this
is not just true in Washington stays
true all over this country which is why
loggers get so upset about
environmentalists and basically they
want to bring an industrial park to
create jobs the oyster fishery people
saying don't you dare the small city
Raymond Washington has no sewage system
there is no outfall to the ocean which
and oysters are extremely sensitive to
pollution so what we have done not we
but really Ecotrust Wilbur Bay Alliance
and many other organizations and I
participated in this and so forth is in
a sense design a zero-emission
industrial park which is in a sense
bringing in industries that are
closed-loop manufacturers that do not
require and will not use any sewage
system whatsoever
always will be processed on site and so
what happened is in so doing you took
this is a community where the loggers
the fishermen the farmers everybody
hated the environmentalists nobody liked
environmental
and now you have a solution of the
environmentalists the fishermen the
loggers the farmers the townspeople the
unemployed loggers our own happy birth
now this is a town that makes studs
it makes two-by-fours right this is a
town that hasn't built a new house for
15 15 years
that's how sad it is in terms of its
economy because it is exactly like a
third-world country
it's exporting all its capital to more
developed nations in the United States
right and wondering why your kids drop
out and take drugs and leave town and no
houses are being built and so what we're
doing is not just ecological restoration
the industries are using red alder which
Weyerhaeuser has been spraying with
helicopters and killing to make
furniture making essential oils from the
green waste from the logging starting
some things with the fisheries and
salmon doing a brewery doing a new soap
factory based on a new French technology
I won't go into those right now but the
point is that in ecological restoration
you talking about social restoration and
there was a there's a man in Pittsburgh
named Bill Strickland has a vocational
school he took it over for children at
risk which is a euphemism primarily for
minority students he took it over it
wasn't working at all so we got rid of
all the vocational courses and they
still didn't work so I didn't got rid of
all the academic courses and all he
taught was art and he taught those kids
singing dancing poetry jazz rather
whatever and what happened is that it
began to feel that they were valued for
the first time that there was something
inherent in them intrinsic to who they
were that was perceived and seen as
being talent as being valuable as being
good so forth they began to change their
sense of themselves to began to accrete
to them their academic and other skills
that they needed in a sense to further
what is what they wanted to do and you
know with a very high placement to this
day in colleges in Pennsylvania but he
said something which really stuck he
said you can't teach kids algebra if
they don't want to be here and I thought
he meant at the school and he wasn't
talking about the school he's talking
about here here on earth
and that's what our kids are telling us
is that we don't have just a waste
problem a landfill problem an atmosphere
problem we have exactly the same problem
in society and we have a whole
generation shooting each other shooting
up engaging an extraordinary high risk
behavior all of it to try to communicate
to us and say you know something I don't
want to be here you have not made a
world I want to be here and why not why
is it they're going to do what jobs do
we offer them that make sense to give
them dignity that gives them respect to
give them meaning nothing and so instead
of course we're going to build more
prisons to hire more guards but when
they're trying to communicate with us so
when we're talking about a restorative
economy we're not talking about linking
social restoration and environmental
restoration linking is what you do on a
phone conversation we're talking about
the fact that they're identical they're
exactly the same thing there is no
separation between social environment
restoration and we have to understand
that in system and industrial system
that D values natural systems is not
going to respect human beings or living
systems and so when we're talking about
the things that call Jaime we're talking
about really for the first time looking
at our problems in an integrated way and
seeing that they're intimately connected
and not trying to solve them with just
simply more taxes or more bureaucrats or
more programs to basically buy off the
poor or buy off the people who have been
marginalized by an industrial system
then no longer values people so the work
is very very exciting I'll just close
with one thing with jean-michel cousteau
said and he's quoting I think an Indian
poet as I remember but he said that in
the end we will protect the things that
we love and and the rest of that is of
course that we love the things that we
know
you know what have been we've been
removed from those truths you know and
we're talking about bringing these
truths to go these are truths that we
can all understand we don't need a
degree to understand these truths to
understand what it is that we want to do
how it is that we can get there and
that's why it's so exciting and that's
why I think it will be a bottom-up
phenomenon and that's why I think I'm so
excited about the environmental movement
because there's no leader
there was no charismatic leader there's
no religion there's no cult there's no
central power structure it mimics the
thing it wants to see happen which is
it's I'm struck by the parallels and our
thinking you know strikes me more is
that many other many many other people
have the same thinking and we didn't
have to talk to each other to come to it
it arises out of the situation the truth
is inherent in natural systems as
opposed to being imposed upon it and
that's why the environmental movement is
going to win and we have to start acting
that way and take responsibility as
designers we are all designers of this
system we're not going to lose we're not
going to lose this is going to be there
is going to be ecological Reformation
social Reformation or a lifetime and
it's time that we took that
responsibility on as opposed to
environmentalists sort of being on the
outskirts or off stage shouting saying
you know I told you so and hoping the
ship goes down now we have to know that
this is going to happen these truths
can't be stopped
thank you very much and I we have to do
did you know did you know this is not
true today but a few years ago when a
Chinese person drank a coke like this
that they doubled their fossil fuel
energy consumption for the day
I'm thirsty the question the question is
where where can you find the book in the
bookstore and you don't that the
business community has not exactly
embraced this work it's a tough book for
business because it's a wake up call is
a little bit of a like wake up we have a
problem and the interesting thing about
it well the fascinating thing about it
is the prior two books which are the
next economy and growing a business were
reviewed and most of the business press
The Wall Street Journal Business Week
Barron's you know intrapreneur Forbes
etc not one single business publication
reviewed this book didn't review it no I
did an article free no so I found that
very interesting so and I had trouble
finding the book too in bookstores so
but on the other hand what who has sort
of sort of taken to the book as people
in public policy and who are really
dealing excuse me with the problems on a
community level in town cities regions
they have really taken to the book and
it's been very popular overseas to the
American version has in ten languages in
the next year but but I mean already so
I'm talking to the Mexican government
I'm talking to governments in many
countries but not so much discovered
well I think it takes a process that's
safe and I don't think we have created
safe I mean that's certainly what Peter
Steinke and is doing here is creating
safe dialogic processes but I mean I
don't think we've created one around
this issue for business yet and so you
get because you have the split between
least cost least price you know you get
businesses doing the most foolish things
you know to sincere I have to say but
foolish to try to win over and curry
favor in terms of their environmental
awareness you get McDonald's and EDF you
know going from polystyrene to paper
clamshells you know when you know
everybody knows the environmental
problem is inside the clamshell right
you know whereas a pound of beef is 2500
litres of water and it's destroying 270
million acres of western grazing land
and you know basically depleting the
Ogallala Aquifer the largest fresh body
body of freshwater in the world and the
main major cause of deforestation and
you know they want to go to a paper
clamshell and and and and but what we
have to do is rather than and just make
fun of that which I do mercilessly but
but is is point out that we that there
in the lease probably system and they
have to basically have a non perverse
incentives in order to change and in
many cases they don't in many cases they
do so forth
[Music]
I have two two responses to that in the
intelligent product system what they're
talking about is utilities that are
citizen owned called parking lots for a
better example but basically those who
have whether it's spent fuel which is
but very tricky technically but let's
talk about just toxins that can be
stored in glass line metal barrels what
they're saying is that those have to be
stored at these parking lots you can't
store them yourself in other words you
may produce them you may have them but
you can't keep them you have to store
them and these you know literally
they're parking lots they're concrete
structures that are multi level and you
have drums parked there like cars that
contain the toxins that cannot be
detoxified right now because
incineration does not detoxify just
changes the toxins and and that those
companies didn't have to pay a rental
fee no it's for that which does two
things one is it it doesn't it gives
them incentives to figure out what to do
with it number one eventually because
they're going to pay for it in
perpetuity otherwise secondly it takes
the responsibility out of their hands
directly until they do come up with a
scientifically proven way to detoxify
whatever it is it may be now there's
another part to that which is the spent
fuel which was talking about timelines
that no civilization has ever
encountered or planned upon twenty five
to two hundred thousand years and one of
the most interesting proposals I have
seen was first of all what I thought was
disastrous and then it was a very
interesting response was from first
Americans and that is to put it on
reservations I thought oh god here we go
again
you know it's can you believe it you
know first we you know they're we exile
them from their exiled land because we
found uranium on it and then we're going
to you know you know put back plutonium
other radioactive waste but it
and it does seem sort of like a another
type of cultural imperialism and it is
accepting that one of the tribes said no
we think you're right you don't know
what to do with this stuff and we have a
culture you know that does think long
term and you don't so better give it to
us because we think we can take better
care of it than you can and that's in a
sense be our duty you know for the earth
it's now favor to you it's a favor to
ourselves but there's also a group
forming Joanna Macy and others you know
what's very interesting who's who to
create a kind of a warrior not a
fighting but it's like a class of people
a Guardians who pass on the information
lore for thousands of years and how do
you start that now to take care of spent
race that's a very interesting project
that's being undertaken so it's pretty
interesting you talk about plutonium the
culture yes
right side up a good question and the
next book this is called natural
capitalism is about that and and what we
have to do is we have to show people in
inner cities people who are on or
underemployed in rural areas we have to
show unions that are seeing you know
their membership atrophy and we have to
show businesspeople that a true cost
system is in all their interests because
the fact is when we go to true cost when
you go to a system rewards natural
capital productivity you create a
climate of innovation change that is
makes the super information highway look
like basically an electrical job because
right now
so much of the technologies and ideas
that would accomplish these increments
and productivity are basically unny
Konami and so by basically we're not
just not costing things that their true
cost we are subsidizing their depletion
there's really not a resource in this
country that is subsidized isn't
subsidized water soil minerals oil coal
forest products fisheries we're also we
the taxpayer is subsidizing the
depletion so when we talk about a true
costing we're talking about releasing
innovation in a subsidized system right
we are suppressing the imagination their
creativity and the best instincts of our
people whether they're on the top or
whether they're on the bottom right now
and so where we have to do in sort of
pedagogically is really show that this
is true so it doesn't come out as a
win-lose you know topsy-turvy
let's shifted sort of thing is going to
require study a lot of thought also has
to be phased in over a very long time
twenty years i'm using so that it is not
disruptive it's not dislocating so you
can engage in long-term planning that's
rational that makes sense that you can
have unitive to any one group yes
[Music]
it is super focused on top of us by
political decisions is not all nature it
is a plan just like in eastern countries
which we are
in the name which is actually in part of
the to me part of the process of the
exercise is to get our language straight
here because when you know it's funny
when you go and I took economics 101
as in high school actually as a
correspondence course from Cal when I
was a junior but but the first chapter
defines income you know an income is
what you can take and leave the capital
intact right oh yeah
and so you know when people say well how
you going to price it you know I mean
who's to say what the true cost of a
Sequoia or a mineral deposit or you know
the water is and so forth that's easy
you know if freshman economists can do
that one because basically either we're
going to preserve an increase capital or
we're going to deplete it so the cost is
what we can take in a year and leave the
capital attack that's our income that's
the cost of those products now when we
have a system that subsidizes them that
guarantees the right of private property
owners you know to treat it in any way
they can and so forth
there's no way that we have a tax system
that can distinguish between income and
capital and that's why I go back to the
thing I want to I want to try a
capitalist system maybe it isn't any
good maybe Marx is right but we haven't
tried yet and I really want to see us
try a system that distinguishes between
income and capital and recognizes and
where everybody knows the difference
even a fifth-grader yes one more
question then we should
[Music]
what two things two things specifically
in general we turn the tax system if you
have to do everything in a
revenue-neutral
way so that no one feels threatened by
these changes you know so there's not in
equities or big inequities built into
that change second of all when you look
at things systemically you realize that
the system is the lever and there is no
one lever so it's not the demand side
it's not supply science not consumer
it's not corporate it's all of those
plus taxation plus municipal plus so the
admits they're like a cop-out but you
know we were used to a hierarchical
patriarchal top-down dominated sort of
way of problem solving and what's so
healthy about the way we're going to
solve these problems is it's not going
to be that way and of course all those
who studied TQM know that Demings
observation about quality circles came
from watching women you know work not
men you know it was the women who got to
go in a circle at the munitions plant
during the war and tried to figure out
what they were doing during the day and
tried to do it better the next day and
that's why they all produced the men on
the other line because they sat in the
circle so really what we're talking
about is creating not only just cyclical
in terms of the systems but terms of how
they relate to each other and what I
really esteem and admire about what Carl
Heinrich is doing is he's basically
getting people talking together in a
circle who have been arguing together
opposites and that's what we have to do
in this country I mean we can talk about
technical fixes the really process has
to precede those fixes it's got to be a
process where we as Americans can start
to listen to each other and right now we
can't and I'll close with one story that
Stuart brand told me when he was in
Kenya and he went to a classroom and he
was talking and a boy in the back eight
years old raised his hand said mr. bran
can you stop tonight mister said what he
said mr. brand so Stuart walk you walk
[Music]
so I just want to thank both of our
speakers karl-henrik and Paul thank you
very much for a quite extraordinary
couple of hours I can't help but think
that the earth itself is shaken with
what we're considering here and I'm
convinced these days that there are no
more coincidences and perhaps a shake-up
or two is appropriate so I trust this
will be the first of more in this vein
and I thank you again very much
[Applause]